il preview seppi sud sono una ragazza e
ciò il maestro sta che pranzando loro
distanti voi non potete cucinare cucino
io con le mie 10 per lanciano 3 pure
vuole più manualità di moie manualità
l'avete capita rendese peas sono una
ragazza ecc al maestro giorno porca
[ __ ] che botta comunque questo video
ragazzi lo sto facendo con il mio amico
pablo che mi è spuntato sotto l'occhio
ciao pablo salutarli pablo contento di
vedermi e gli attenti ragazzi e
benvenuto che sono video sono farisei
oggi siamo tornati su questo dolcissimo
gioco chiamato jan chiamato gli under e
simulator allora hanno aggiunto perché
ogni tanto questo gioco lo aggiornano
erano aggiunto un sacco di kakà telle
tipo mission mode non solo sindaco è la
madonna ciò se troppo è migliore del mio
random mission design mission lo dimise
fa in mission hill sheen napoli missioni
che devi ammazzare persone ma che figata
proprio chavanel cinematica no aveva che
figata l'anno aggiornato di brutto io
non mi fai neanche scegliere le mutande
come in tutti gli altri under e vabbè
eccolo eccolo e questo no questo davanti
chi cazzo è e questa ecco questo è
questo qua ciao sheen jackie quindi è
questo coi capelli un po mi chiamo di
giocare indovina chi
ma perché siete tutti qua ci sono 800
armadietti perché dovete attaccarvi
tutti nello stesso cosa tocchi tutti i
maniaci st scuola fottutamente sta
andando perché quelli coi capelli blu
stanno andando da una parte sola quelli
che i capelli blu discriminano gli altri
stranissima starò a solo nella stanza
del rituale quindi se un rituale si un
figlio di satana
quindi è anche facile trovare il modo di
ucciderlo però non posso no no e no io
guarda cosa ci sto facendo in questo
coltello ce l'avete voi come dovuto per
terra e lo ha buttato l'ho votato per
fare benissimo ceneri nella stanza nel
rituale c'è un coltello lo prendo cosa
ci fai con quel coltello era lì cazzo
devo capire un attico stai leggendo come
scortare la mia famiglia
mi piace questa vedi che ci sono i pezzi
di arti sul libro perché se premo il
tasto chi compare una scia che mi dice
di andare verso di 43 qua dentro
e perché mai a perché devo andare in
club che non lo sapevo io allora per
uscire una persona mi serve l'educazione
fisica bene e lunedì pomeriggio perfetto
lunch time dove shinji ceco ragazzi
c'era una parte mettersi il tostapane in
testa c'era un modo per mandare veloce
il tempo fra eccolo eccolo dove è andato
no mica sarà allontanato dal momento
perfetto non ti seria di vino basta
leggere libri basta l'educazione
facetime fino alle 2 andiamo a chrome
anno molto bello divertente sì ma hai
rotto le palle basta seguirlo di
soppiatto ragazzi stato non dovrebbe
accorgersi di me in teoria perché cazzo
stanno facendo wales inglobando a
vicenda
ma cos'è stare un orgia minchia che due
palle o no fermo che poi non lo vedi più
switch hair make the club sunshine zia
di arriva uno schiaffo ci faccio volare
tutti i capelli di faccio volare vabbè
comunque non trovavo il tizio mi son
tornato qua però il problema è che a me
serve ucciderlo quindi non è che me ne
frega ritornare in classe da te misto
numero di telefono che gli chiedo dov'è
rimasta lì ma in grado di uccidere una
persona non sono capaci stalker area
ecco lo stronzo dove dove minchia eri
maledetto deficiente eh beh vedo che
comunque la vita ti sorride rivi e
deputato assassinando sulle scale date
minar ma adesso ogni lui scende di cui
poi al club se riesco andare al club
prima io a prendere il coltello e poi
salire di nuovo ucciderlo datemi un
coltello prendilo eccole qua il coltello
prendo premio premio la voce
non mi ha visto nessuno a parte te
quindi non uccidere anche tessuta è bene
bene prendi il corpo veloce veloce cazzo
ti dovesse mi fai capire come fa a
essere così forte una tipa che oltre ad
uscire una persona la prende anche in
braccio e oltre a prenderla in braccio è
bellissimo perché tiene anche il frappè
in bocca alla famiglia o perfetto
neanche bisogno di aprire le porte fanta
bello così nascondino sotto il palco
anche penseranno che sia di scena
fantastico banca di sponsor fondi spos
clothing and move up blog
ok solo ad andare a pulirmi veloce
veloce l'accesso veloce a zero anche al
46 guarda 5 secondi ma porca eva teneva
qua nuda nuda nuda brava zia a posto non
c'è più e vestiti sono pulito io a cazzo
non proprio pulito pulisciti patrizio
cioè la doccia non si pulisce e stupida
da raga non ci credo mission face la
polizia arriva e vabbè ma non si pulisce
sono la vasca da bagno nuova missione
ragazzi se mi concentro ce la posso fare
non vi preoccupate musume rorschach per
madonna quanto è brutta però almeno ora
la riconosco quindi accetto
allora facciamo così per stavolta
andiamo a prima prendere l'arma del
delitto subito la vado a posizionare i
piani di sopra quando siamo nelle scale
la marzo ecco la mazza da baseball
ammazzo lo so lo so io lo sento ancora
lì la [ __ ] eccola qua non essa che
vedere dove chi minchia se ne va quindi
aspettiamo facetime che cazzo sta
facendo quella è tutta scema ragazze che
sta lavorando questo video anche voi
fate così con l'amica perché se fate
così ci sono dei problemi seri alla
gente non mi può vedere visibilmente
armata vada in mente una mazza da
baseball e potrei fare qualsiasi cosa
una mazza da baseball e anche farci la
pizza con la mazza da baseball
mattarello tipo se io vado in classe
uccido tutti quelli che stanno nella sua
classe può funzionare la ecco l'ho presa
e l'ho presa ragazzi sta arrivando st
rivas basta guardare dove va basta
guardare solo doveva ammazzano adesso
perfetto ma i pick up ci credo non sia
noi che sangue c'è fantastico l'ho
ammazzata così chiare alto
professionismo e di
solo fonini cup al replay fighissimo nel
senso posso spesso posso di ammazzarla
ok type lingue pensavo che facesse
rivedere tutto invece no replay che ci
per rigiocare va bene posso fare perché
l'altra volta non c'erano 16 e adesso
c'erano cheadle loro quando spunta che
cazzo è affinché non finiscono me ne
vado non frega niente cioè ormai sonon
fissati cosa allora rifacciamo tutto
come prima fare tutto come prima devo
andare qua lasciare l'arma cui andare
sopra alla mia classe e aspettarla qua
per forza ok dai ce la posso fare dai
sono in anticipo è maledetta stronza che
mi devi sembra un belle palle che non ci
manca solo che mi rimproveri e di nuovo
l'una o che perfetto allora siamo
arrivati a luna ti devi togliere adesso
appena la vedo passare mollo il telefono
subito prendo la mazza la uccido e poi
sto attento a portarla perché un giorno
porca [ __ ] che botta ok va bene anche
così problema è che la mazza adesso è
sporca di sangue però va bene che svetta
in faccia fortissimo cazzo ti ha fatto
st cristiano metto qua
tanto poi non centra mai nessuno prendi
la mazza veloce
metti l'acqua anche la mazza ora sono
sporco di sangue cosa che prima non lo
ero devo andare a cambiarmi vestiti
lavarmi completamente perché sono
sporche di sangue poi tornare lì e
incenerirla bene adesso ce la posso fare
come ci si lava visto posto e un bagno
maledizione lavati ma seduto ai vestiti
nell'acqua si lavano non si lavano posso
farmi un bagno per cortesia per favore
serve a questo il ban c'ero riuscito una
volta a eccolo minchia una una vita e
non andavano bay solo questo andava bene
va bene i vestiti e mi dovrò mettere
qualcosa ma subito uscire nudo i cambi e
vestiti no no no così no però g milioni
ho dato subito la palestra va bene sono
un po
un provocante però allora butto questi
all'inceneritore prima notizia
direttamente la tipa equa chiudi la
porta però magari che ne dici ci sono
indizi di prima teste di minchia vede
non c'è nessuno porca eva solo quando
c'è una tipa in mano dovrà pagare le
palle ce ne dispiace nell'inserirsi
tutto vai forte sega minchia perso tutto
il sun che palle adesso dei per del
sangue porca eva vai pure lei via posso
buttare anche la mazzata beta di vista
ne frega se lo sto cambio è non fare
cazzate perfetto vai e tutto dentro
brucia non c'è mettere anche tanto
l'unica roba che manca e pulire per
terra perché se sporco di sangue
potrebbe esserci un problema quindi
datemi un mocio posso usare questo senza
puliti senza l'acqua ma sì chi se ne
frega jolo senza l'acqua sta andando a
pulire perché sono brava studentessa
sull acqua non funzionerebbe mai ma
vabbè ho finito non c'è più obiettivi ho
fatto lo rimetto a posto tanto non è
manco sporco di sangue bene io direi che
vado a controllare che sia incenerita
per bene poi in teoria dovrei e sarà poi
in teoria 47 minuti quindi verso le 3
meno un quarto un quarto alle tre di
penne dove mica siete dovrebbe andare
quindi start rating buy ma quanto è
difficile la vita da killer che i miei
tempi i cadaveri si bruciavano meglio
vabbè allora ho ammazzato una persona
non esiste piu finisco la mia giornata
giornale giornata finisca la mia
giornata normalmente
e così nessuno si trasferisce tipo la
tipa che sono arrivato in ritardo a di
capaci e gtc questa educazione zia ti
insegno io resto è tutto finito
sono al via hanno cambiato anche
l'entrata tra l'altro figata da come ho
finito ragazzi sono a posto
sto gioco una merda ma ma mi sono
divertito
l'importante questo vale ai ragazzi è
stato bellissimo contento di essere
riuscito ho fatto tutto 1 devo fare a
fan culo se poi siete stronzi voi che
non funziona se stesso non si può io ho
fatto tutto ragazzi spero che mi sia
piaciuto e cosa sensi che bisogno c'è un
momento è un mi piace anche a pagina di
facebook e comodo trascrizione sono
serviti sia tecnici che diavolo fossimo
vinto dai ragazzi